Hallo Leute, sinnloser Kreisel-Crime startet wieder.
Ich habe mir gedacht, ich mache heute mal den Stream an dabei.
Ich weiß, Montagvormittag, wobei offiziell ist es schon Nachmittag.
Offiziell ist es ja ab quasi 12 vor 1.
Aber im Prinzip für mich ist halb eins immer noch Vormittag.
Wahrscheinlich Montagvormittag, bei weitem nicht wirklich viele Leute am Start hier.
Der Feuer, der ist immer da.
Ich weiß nicht, wie du das machst, ob du auf dem Handy schreibst oder so.
Aber du bist gefühlt immer da, du bist immer am Start.
Aber nice, nice.
Ich hoffe, der Sound passt von der Lautstärke her halbwegs.
Muss man gleich mal gucken.
Gerade Mittagspause, okay.
Ja, ich mache auch Mittagspause.
Ich habe gerade mega, mega viel gefressen.
Oh, Server-Reboot gleich.
Nice.
Ich habe mega viel gefressen.
Und wollte jetzt mit meinem Daily-MMO-Kreisel-Crime starten.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, ich habe schon eine Weile nicht mehr da aufgestreamt.
Ich streame einfach mal eine Runde.
Ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher, was wir heute machen.
Du musst Werbung gucken?
Was?
Man muss zu Werbung gucken, MonkaS.
Was soll das denn?
Also wir müssen halt einige Sachen machen ingame.
Und ob ich die jetzt alleine mache oder on stream mache, da können ja diejenigen, die Bock haben, zugucken.
Ich weiß, für die meisten sitzt da auch nicht so das Spannende.
Im Vergleich zu dem, was ich sonst mache, bringe ich es hier gleich Server-Reboot in 15 Sekunden.
Da wird PogChamp automatisch ausgelockt.
Ich sollte mal hier weggehen, dass ich nicht mitten in den Mobs spawne gleich.
Hm.
OneDog++, später.
Ich brauche ein paar Auto-Hotkey-Scripts für meinen Heiler.
Da müssen wir vielleicht ein bisschen Makro-Programmieren-Hackermans machen.
Wobei ich mir gar nicht sicher bin, ob ich Auto...
Wtf, Alter, wie laut ist der Launcher, bitteschön?
Moment.
Warte mal, wo ist der?
Hat der Launcher kein...
Alter...
Der Launcher ist lauter als alles andere, Mann.
Alter, wie laut der Launcher ist.
Kack-Wait.
Dabei habe ich so...
Habe ich... Habe ich nice...
Mittelalterliche Entspannungsklänge im Hintergrund an.
Aber der Launcher haut recht rein.
So, gucken wir mal, ob der Server rebooted ist.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das jetzt reboot ist.
Natürlich...
Tolles Timing.
Okay, Reboot.
Nice.
Let's go.
Meinung zu Baldur's Gate 3.
Mega-Game.
Lässt im dritten Akt ein bisschen nach.
Ich habe es noch nicht ganz durchgespielt.
Ich werde es durchspielen, wenn es wie bei Larian Games üblich dann irgendwann so eine Definitive...
Wie auch immer Edition gibt.
Also.
Wir haben heute ein paar Sachen vor.
Ja.
Also.
Beziehungsweise.
Ich.
Ihr könnt zugucken.
Und...
Also.
Wir müssen heute...
Wir müssen heute ein paar Sachen machen.
Also.
Ich muss auf jeden Fall meinen Huni auf 50 springen.
Das ist easy.
Der ist gleich durch.
Der muss die Epic machen.
Der Heiler muss Epic machen.
Der...
Ähm...
Huni braucht CL5.
Der Heiler nicht.
Ich logge mal den Huni ein.
Mal gucken, was jetzt...
Mal gucken, was jetzt kommt.
Und nebenbei machen wir noch ein bisschen PvP.
Mal gucken, was da so geht.
Hallo?
Dann nebenbei machen wir noch ein bisschen PvP und gucken, was da so geht.
Wenn ihr Fragen zum Game habt, ne?
Immer her damit.
Ich glaube, es gibt kaum ein Game, wo ich mich trauen würde zu sagen,
ich kann euch so gut wie alles zu sagen.
Aber Dark ist das Game, wo ich doch am nächsten dran bin, ey.
So.
Dann lasst uns mal kurz gucken.
Es sieht so aus, als gibt es gleich eine Runde Gratis-Level.
Da gehe ich doch gleich mal hin.
Porten wir mal zurück.
Ähm...
Habe ich meinen Reshade an?
Ja, Reshade ist an.
Ohne Reshade sieht das Game sehr farblos aus.
Guckt euch das mal an.
So.
Oh, super.
So ist...
So ist normal.
Und so ist mit Reshade.
Sieht einfach deutlich besser aus.
Da sieht das Game ein bisschen mehr so aus, wie zu Zeiten, als das auf dem CRT gespielt wurde.
Verfolgst du irgendwelche Sportarten?
Tatsächlich relativ wenig.
Das Einzige...
Was ich...
Tatsächlich regelmäßig so ein bisschen verfolge, ist Radsport.
Nicht erst seit ich selbst wieder fahre, sondern...
Eigentlich schon...
Eigentlich schon relativ lang.
Und...
Ansonsten...
Ist jetzt aber auch nicht, dass ich da super deep da hier drinne bin.
So.
Guck mal hier, die ganzen Low-Level-Noobs am Start.
Also...
Wenn man in dem Game Low-Level-Noobs erkennt, dann liegt das daran, dass sie so aussehen wie meins.
So richtig...
So richtig noobisch.
So mit grauer Rüstung.
Grauer Level-Rüstung.
Mollwig-Armor.
Also...
Hier siehst du gleich...
Char mit Epic.
Wobei auch nicht alles.
Ja.
Char mit Epic.
Höchstwahrscheinlich Template an.
Ordentlich im Umhang.
Skin und allem.
Und dann...
Guckst du mich an.
Und ich seh halt aus wie Level 1.
So im Endeffekt.
So.
Wer hat denn BG für diesen ganzen Grempel hier?
Gucken wir mal.
Schauen wir mal wie viele Leute in der BG drin sind.
69.
Nice.
Dann suche ich mir mal ne Group.
Hm.
Auf geht's.
Brauche ich ne neue Brille oder Captured OBS Reshade nicht?
Äh.
Doch.
OBS sollte Reshade Capturen.
Sekunde.
Wartet mal.
Lass mich mal kurz im...
Es ist aus?
Ja.
Auf jeden Fall.
Guck mal.
An.
Aus.
Guck dir mal an wie grau das ist wenn es aus ist.
Versus relativ farbenfroh wenn es an ist.
Äh.
By the way.
Ich glaube.
Sind die Gamesounds zu laut?
Mal kurz gucken wie laut ich die gestellt habe.
Weil da auch Gamesounds.
Ne 4% ist okay.
Da auch Gamesounds sind halt so ein bisschen 2001 mäßig.
Ich glaube das geht halbwegs.
Man kann es halt in OBS nicht richtig kontrollieren.
Lass mich mal kurz auf dem Handy.
Auf dem Handy checken wie die Lautstärke so ist.
Weil mir erscheinen die.
Mir erscheinen die Gamesounds.
Die sind ein Ticken.
Ein Ticken laut.
Lass mal kurz gucken.
Oh Leute.
Ich hab den.
Ha.
Mir fällt der gerade auf.
Lull.
Äh.
Video.
Output.
Ich muss den.
Den Output hochstellen.
Falls das überhaupt geht live.
Ich hoffe das geht live.
Ja.
Geht.
Ne.
Oder?
Lass mal.
Sieht man das auf Twitch?
Konnte man sich das auf Twitch nicht angucken?
Oder auch nicht?
Hm.
Sekunde.
Ich hab vergessen die Qualität hochzustellen.
Wartet mal.
Ähm.
Kurz mal sticken.
Da ich nichts verpasse.
Es ist Eden.
Ja.
Eden.
Wobblords.
Twitch.
Hat das jetzt die Bitrate hochgestellt?
Warte mal.
Hat das die Bitrate hochgestellt?
Wo ging das nochmal?
Das war doch irgendwo hier auf.
Advanced.
Video Stats.
Welche Bitrate haben wir gerade?
4,9.
Das stellt die Bitrate nicht hoch.
Okay.
Ähm.
Ich drück mal kurz auf Stream Stop.
Stream Start.
Damit.
Damit die Bitrate hochgeht.
Weil.
Ich dachte eigentlich, dass das mittlerweile on the fly geht.
Aber anscheinend geht das mit dem Hardware Encoder nicht.
Hardware Encoder nicht on the fly.
Ich.
Moin.
Die Clips.
Ich drück Stop.
Ich drück Start.
Ihr könnt quasi in 20 Sekunden.
Könnt ihr refreshen.
Ja.
Nicht, dass ihr euch wundert, warum er jetzt weg ist.